George R.R. Martin: You know, I'm notorious
for my love of grey characters and one of
the greyest characters in the entire Westeros
is Daemon Targaryen, the Rogue Prince.
We took one of the sidebars and made a seperate
story out of it, the Rogue Prince.
Daemon is the younger brother of King Viserys
I, for a time he was the heir to the throne
when Viserys had no children, and then Viserys
started having children and he stopped being
the heir to the throne.
He's a notorious bad boy, a rogue in every
sense of the word.
He was a rival for Viserys' sister and his
own niece Rhaenyra and then later he became
the husband of Rhaenyra.
He swtiches sides several times, you never
know what side he's going to come down on.
He's a very colorful and unpredictable character
and I think he has to rank up there as my
favorite.
Viserys Targaryen: When ravens carried the
news of Aegon's coronation to Dragonstone,
Princess Rhaenyra summoned her own Black Council.
With her was her uncle and husband, Daemon
Targaryen, considered by many to be the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
Robert Baratheon: Arrax was struggling to
stay aloft in the gale when a roar shook the
very foundations of Storm's End.
Aemond rose through the clouds and below him
the monstrous Vhagar.
Vhagar was five times the size of Arrax and
a hardened survivor of a hundred battles.
Vhagar caught him above Shipbreaker Bay.
Watchers on the castle walls saw distant blasts
of flame and heard a shriek drown out the
thunder.
Prince Lucerys fell, broken, to be swallowed
by the waves.
With his death, the war of ravens came to
an end, and the war of fire and blood began.
Catelyn Stark: When Rhaenyra heard of her
son's death, she collapsed.
She considered ending the war right then until
a raven arrived from her husband, Daemon.
Her son would be avenged.
Whispers slithered through the taverns and
back alleys of Flea Bottom.
Two men were found; one was a former gold
cloak, the other a rat catcher in the Red
Keep who knew all its secrets.
History remembers them only as Blood and Cheese.
One night, Queen Helaena entered the royal
apartments with her daughter and two sons
to put them to bed.
Without warning, Blood and Cheese burst in,
daggers in hand.
They told her that a debt was owed.
A son for a son.
Viserys: Rhaenyra's forces struck yet another
blow.
The moment the Lord of Harrenhal saw Daemon
Targaryen circling the castle on his dragon
Caraxes, he struck his banners and surrendered.
The Blacks now had the strongest castle in
the Riverlands.
Robert: After Rook's Rest, Aemond One-Eye
took command of the Greens from his crippled
and poppy-addled brother.
Aemond was the blood of the dragon, and dragons
don't cower behind city walls.
He marched the king's army north to take back
Harrenhal from Rhaenyra's husband, Daemon.
But when he and Criston Cole reached the castle,
they found the gates open, with Daemon and
all his men gone.
That night they feasted their victory; Daemon
had fled rather than face their wrath.
But Daemon was more snake than dragon.
As Aemond marched north, he'd flown Caraxes
south, slithering past the Green army over
the waters of the Gods Eye.
One day King's Landing looked up and saw two
dragons circling their foul city.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had come for her throne,
for the city was defenseless.
Aemond had taken the king's army from the
city, and worse, he'd taken his dragon Vhagar.
Seeing that resistance was hopeless, the small
council surrendered the city, the Queen Mother
Alicent, and the broken Queen Helaena.
But not King Aegon.
Somehow, despite his wounds and delirium,
he had vanished from the city.
Viserys: When a new army of Green loyalists
marched up from the Reach and laid siege to
the city of Tumbleton, Rhaenyra sent two of
her dragonseeds to lay waste to them.
Instead, the dragonseeds proved their bastard
nature and betrayed her.
They burned the city and all the Black forces
garrisoned within.
Lucky for her, they didn't turn towards King's
Landing but drank in the ruins with the Greens,
who were victorious and somewhat confused.
Oberyn Martell: Rhaenyra now mistrusted all
the dragonseeds, including the girl who rode
with her husband Daemon, hunting Aemond in
the Riverlands.
She ordered the girl's head be sent to her.
But there was a complication.
As well as her dragon, the girl had taken
to riding Daemon.
When Daemon received the queen's order, he
proclaimed it a queen's words and a work.
He sent the girl away at dawn, watching her
and her dragon vanish into the morning mists.
Then Daemon sent a challenge to his nephew
Aemond and flew to Harrenhal alone to wait.
Fourteen days later, a shadow blacker than
any passing cloud swept over Harrenhal.
Vhagar had come at last and on her rode one-eyed
Prince Aemond.
He mocked Daemon for facing him alone.
"You have lived too long, uncle."
And Daemon replied, "On that much, we agree."
Then the old prince climbed stiffly onto the
back of his dragon Caraxes but neglected to
fasten the chains that secured rider to saddle.
The sun was close to setting when, as one,
the two dragons leapt into the sky.
Daemon took Caraxes up swiftly until he disappeared
into a bank of clouds.
Vhagar, older and slower, ascended more gradually.
Up and up, Vhagar soared, searching for Caraxes.
Sudden as a thunderbolt, a shrieking Caraxes
dove upon Vhagar.
Locked together, the dragons tumbled toward
the lake.
Caraxes' jaws closed upon Vhagar's neck, but
Vhagar ripped open Caraxes's belly, and her
teeth ripped off a wing.
The lake rushed up with terrible speed.
Then Daemon Targaryen, who had never fastened
his riding chains, stood in his saddle.
He leapt from his dragon to Aemond's, and
in his hand was Dark Sister, the Valyrian
sword of Aegon's sister-queen Visenya.
As Aemond One-Eye looked up in terror, Daemon
ripped off his nephew's helm and drove the
sword down into his one remaining eye so hard
the point came out the back of the young prince's
throat.
Half a heartbeat later, the dragons struck
the lake, sending up a gout of water so high
that it was said to have been as tall as Harrenhal's
great tower.
The lake boiled with dragon blood and then
was still.
Daemon Targaryen was nine-and-forty at his
death.
Prince Aemond had only turned twenty.
Vhagar, the greatest of the Targaryen dragons,
had counted one-hundred-and-eighty-one years.
Thus passed the last living creature from
the days of Aegon's Conquest.
Viserys: Back in King's Landing, Queen Rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her stupid
husband.
The mad former queen Helaena flung herself
from a balcony, to be impaled upon the iron
spikes lining the moat of Maegor's Holdfast.